so nice getting to talk to you
congratulations
on all of your success uh so much to
talk about so let's get right into it
congratulations on your new single
supermodel is it true that this song is
based on people that you met when you
first came to l.a
yeah it is correct
okay so what were your first impressions
when you came from italy to l.a
oh of course we we had
like the overall impression is very good
yeah let's start saying that because
otherwise it seems like we hate us okay
you love it yes we love it no we we
actually really enjoyed our client there
but
on the other end we saw that
the stereotype of the american dream and
everybody wants to be a celebrity and
everybody wants to be relevant it's it's
actually true
and uh we thought it was just
something that you see on films and
stuff but when we saw that it was true
we just
we just want to
we just wanted to make fun of it because
for us it's
pretty
uh
weird and hilarious so we just we just
took the piece out of it yeah yeah and
like another hand in the other hand
it's like good to
be in
that kind of a
woman because we just discovered a new
culture that we never leave for the
newlands and we often had a chance to be
there in lay for three months in a row
it was really
i mean it was just cool to
have
a bad amount of experiences and
a lot of different flavors so yeah it
was very very nice yeah
i love the music video for this one too
it's very cinematic it almost feels like
a movie were there certain movies that
kind of inspired the feel of this music
video
yeah a bit of the pulp fiction like very
basic but still iconic yeah totally so
yeah but like generally
no like it's perfect it's like one of
the most famous movies ever
but yeah i think we had a lot of fun
also shooting it and it was so funny and
uh even if it looks look good on camera
we were so stupid like running for hours
there and like pulling this back the
whole time so it was pretty hilarious
you guys all looked so good you're so
stylish i just kept looking at
everything you guys were wearing i was
like i want that i want the oh look at
those orange shorts hey now not everyone
can pull those off but they look great
on you right
on outfit
i love it um i also just saw the movie
elvis this is baz lorman's elvis it's so
good and then i was so excited to see
that you're on the soundtrack for this
you get to sing a cover of elvis
presley's if i can dream what was that
like
it was crazy when boss norman contacted
us we
we couldn't believe it was actually true
like elvis of course we grew up
listening to him and he one of the most
i think iconic and influential artists
like in the whole history so for us it
was just an honor to have the chance to
make our own conversation of his music
and to be part of such a good and huge
project and also buzz is really like one
of the most amazing directors and the
whole experience was really cool
like when you think of the soundtrack
you have eminem on there casey musgraves
uh doji cat like
it's the biggest artist ever and you
guys are on there too that must feel so
good it is
good
pretty cool um did you
have you guys seen the movie
yeah we did it
what did you think
it was good
amazing it's so good it's also kind of
sad too to see how things ended for
elvis presley do you think i didn't know
about the manager and and that whole
relationship oh it's so it's very sad
like like the whole ending
it leaves you tearing but it's very good
it's so good have you guys met austin
butler or tom hanks
both
what was that experience like they're
very nice like we met them in canon we
talked a lot
we were at this like dinner for the song
so we had the chance to chat a bit and
it was very nice and he's also doing
like a really really amazing job on the
movie yeah
you also
can really see how excited he is and how
he cares about the whole thing so it's
it's great to see
you guys have had so much success and i
feel like in in kind of a short amount
of time you guys have worked with
rolling stones iggy pop how has life
been like in the past year for you
crazy intense
powerful we can't count all the amazing
and unbelievable things we've done like
from the all the collaborations all the
festivals award show tv shows everything
like there's been so many like crazy and
very good things we could only dream
dream of one year ago so we're very
grateful and
enjoying every moment
does it feel like you just won
eurovision or does that feel like a long
time ago
i love that um you know if you can think
of the artist that you've already worked
with but who you love to work with in
the future is there an artist that you
would love to collaborate with
there's so many things
do you have like a wish list who's like
at the top of the list a couple of
artists that you'd love to work with
jack white
oh good one
well yeah good one i would say miley
cyrus magic monkeys i don't know depends
on what candle ah also bands of course
yes i guys i love this um who has had
the best reaction to all of your success
i don't know i think all of our friends
and family really supports us and
they're so happy for
what we're doing so i think we we're
very lucky because we're in a very good
environment and we feel supported by
everyone
and you guys all still like each other
yeah
it depends
that's so good um so you are kicking off
a tour
loud kids tour tell me how excited you
are for that
maybe yeah we didn't have the chance to
play for for longer or a long time of
course because of the epidemic so now
we're
very happy to to
to be back on tour
uh we're we're gonna tour
america and two gigs in toronto
yes i was just gonna say i know you're
coming to canada yeah i was not sure
yeah
yeah
what
are you looking forward to most coming
to canada
i don't know the whole thing because
we've never been yeah
i don't really know what to expect like
it's just like i would like to see a
raptor escape
oh raptors game good call you're putting
that into the universe you got to find
time to go to a game that'd be awesome i
don't know what's in season or not i'm
not a huge sports person but
you gotta you gotta get tickets
right not be in season when when you
guys come to toronto um you guys have uh
made such a great stance on
being definitive with the idea that rock
and roll is not dead you know we've
heard this from other musicians in the
past you've even said it's impossible to
kill what is it about rock and roll that
you think will live on forever i think
just uh
it it's a kind of music that allows you
like to be free and break the rules and
do something that really represents you
and not to do something just to conform
to the norms or to what is more
mainstream at the music but it really
gives you the chance to experiment and
express what you really feel so i think
like
me since
there are so many big artists that
really made the history but not only on
their
point of view like a musical point of
view but it also translated in like just
revolutionizing just the
the life of people and the way that
some like topics are perceived and
breaking ones and rules so i think
that's one thing that will save forever
i love that um
what is
something about fame because you guys
are
in high demand everyone can't wait to
see you on tour you're working with some
incredible artists what is the one thing
about fame that has surprised you
is it like what you thought is it
everything you thought of
free drinks
you need pre-drinks or you get more
pre-drinks free drinks
oh free drink
that is amazing
that's that's hilarious so people just
give you all the drinks you want
sometimes when you get lucky
i love that um you know i was thinking
about your single supermodel and i feel
like a part of that song too is this
idea that like
you want something that maybe not be
the best for you so speaking of guilty
pleasures uh what would you say are some
of your biggest guilty pleasures
oh
work in separate places
i don't know
angel boy a liar
[Music]
you don't have like a bad food
yes
like i only eat like junk food so
that's all i do you me both sister
[Laughter]
amazing okay so what's the key to why
you guys work so well together
because we are friends basically so we
are
like the first day i met them i i just
thought
they could be like my band of my life
actually
i literally saw that so yeah birthday
just happened dude you like the best
birthday
that's awesome
yeah i thought i told that to my
grandmother yeah i was talking with her
about it
i remember
i like that
um well listen
congratulations on all of your success
i'm so excited to see how the tour
uh goes for you guys to get new music
from you it's just so much has happened
in such a short amount of time you guys
are just
can't wait to see what else you do
thank you so much
thank you
you